thank you alejandro yes i'm here with
florine raduchoy one of the biggest
superstars
in romanian national football florin
welcome to the show
what does it mean for you to see all
these best chess players in the world
come here to bucharest you've seen
a lot of the best football players but
what does it mean about chess players
yeah thank you very much for this
invitation
and uh yes it's true i
it's a very nice sport for me it's a
very very very
very it's it's not easy to play this
this sport
but first of all for me it's a privilege
to see these these
guys these these guys play this
marvelous sport you know so uh
it's it's very interesting it's very
interesting because it's about uh you
know
it's about anticipating uh the the
opponent's move
is about strategy it's a little bit like
a football you know
just to know a little bit before what
what your opponents said you he'll do it
here so
it's very interesting very interesting
is something new for me so i
i would like to thank to everyone here
for or all the people who organize this
uh this tournament
is a privilege for me like a romanian as
a romanian so
we are happy to have to be i'm happy to
be here and to
also i'm very proud to to be here with
uh
in my in my country in my in my town so
you know
i'm really really happy you know what do
you think it means for the younger
generation
uh of chess players uh you as a football
player
when you saw the best just uh the best
football players in the world what did
it mean for you
as a young football player as a young
yeah i i remember
i remember we have we have a very young
player here uh bogdan dak that's i i i
saw his uh
his uh his uh what he's done yesterday
he won
so i'm i'm really proud for this he's
very young he's uh
he has nothing to do nothing to to lose
you know he's a is an outsider
so he's a little bit like like romania
in 94
in in the usa when everyone uh
even when we were doing we were doing a
very nice tournament
we were we were an outside team outside
team you know
so uh we we we've done a
marvelous marvel thing there in america
so it's like like like bognanda also you
know so
so uh i think many many players is
uh is uh they they they afraid him you
know
so uh we will see we'll see what
happened in next days you know
you are one of the most prolific
strikers
uh in the history of the national
romanian team uh
what characteristics would you say uh
chess players could take from football
just players would play yeah uh
i don't know but maybe i i told you i i
i i talk about uh anticipating about you
know anticipating the the
opponents move your moves you know they
say this thing i think is very very
important
and i think there's it is there is many
things similar
but i i think only
it's clear this this sport is for
intelligent people
and i think also that football
nobody no not everyone can play it
because
football is for intelligent people also
so i think
you have to be intelligent to play these
two these two sports you know
and who is your favorite uh player in
this tournament uh
not bogdan deck because he's very young
and i i wish him all
good luck and uh to be to be strong and
and why not why not to be a very one one
day
number one in the world thank you very
much for joining us
thank you very much back to you in the
studio